to listen to her first see if she sounds
reasonable you have to read the captions
to see what it says and then we'll tell
you how you feel about her so started
from the beginning
um
perfect
universities
foreign
foreign
that struck me bro that that is first of
all amazing I love her I didn't watch
the whole thing I saw cliff and how this
is this is how the the left side and the
other side works if you saw that clip
Jed and you didn't have no subtitles you
don't know what the hell she would say
see it they'll take just her yelling and
being aggressive and be like look at how
she looks like a Mussolini look how she
looks like she's aggressive and look at
her anger you have no idea what the hell
she's saying look at the message she
just said she's really woke I loved it
um I loved it and I I you know it's
interesting if I saw like in the chain
people were responding and people were
saying can we get her over here
because and it's true if you if you look
at American politicians there's such a
diluted version of that like that that
looks like a real person that looks
authentic she cares what she's saying it
doesn't look like a program robot coming
out and saying a bunch of talking points
but I think this message is terrifying
to authoritarians it's terrifying to
folks on the left by the way it's
terrifying to folks on the left in this
country because they see the Vigor with
which a lot of people in America
responded to this and they're like oh we
don't want any of that this look at what
she's talking about God country family
Freedom the the power of the individual
she's talking about facts she's talking
about basic facts being ignored that's a
pivot to gender identity she's talking
about the fact that we've just left that
whole Realm of the objective for this
subjective Whatever by which we can
inject woke politics into everything I
thought it was a very very powerful
speech I think it's this is what the
left's been battling in the United
States for a long time I mean you
remember back to the 2008 presidential
election them making fun of people who
clung who were clinging to Bibles and
their guns and going after these
concepts of individual liberty and
individual Freedom so I love seeing it
there I think it's important to see it
there but more than anything Republicans
in this country should be embarrassed
they should watch somebody like that
they should feel lazy they should feel
embarrassed humiliated and somebody
should get off their ass and really
start talking because it's not safe it's
not safe like here like oh freedom is
safe here it's not it's not safe here
and we shouldn't be relying on other
countries and leadership in other
countries to say what we should be
saying and doing here I think the Santas
is the closest if I may is the closest
that we have to that type of leader I
think so the way he speaks the way he
doesn't care the way he doesn't hold
back the way he's just you know raw that
to me that's the female version of
Rhonda Sanders I mean she's that's
that's I'm a fan I love her she's
amazing the question you have to ask is
why it's a very basic question why did
that video go viral why it's a very
basic question why did 19 million people
in how long was it up by the way I'm
actually really curious why did 19 mil
from the moment the guy posted I'm gonna
go to the account was it two days back
yeah why did he this was posted 9 25 22
what's today's date and it was posted at
11 34 PM so it's not really two days
it's really it's really 36 out 35 hours
why has this thing gotten 19 million
views you think because the people want
is it because 19 million people hate it
or it's because 19 million people say
dude this is kind of how I feel and by
the way it's 19 million people who
retweeted this out of the 19 million
people who retweeted how many of them
don't speak Italian
do you realize 19 million people
retweeted a message just to read
captions yeah and to feel her energy
knowing no clue I don't speak Italian
but I relate to this woman how do you
process this atom well
um I'm not ready to anoint her the best
president ever yeah I mean she's been in
office one day so let's just pump the
brakes here if you're about you know
nobody here saying best president ever
exactly people are saying a message that
she gave nobody's totally the president
ever and that allows me to speak about
the message now clearly this is someone
who's passionate speaking with
conviction and people want authenticity
you can tell that she's just like yo
here's the freaking deal so I respect
that but I'm not going to rush to
judgment we're all familiar with the
Jeremy Lin analogy just one way good
game or one good string of games doesn't
make a career so everybody's nobody's
gonna judge her policies the message is
what we're talking about how do you feel
about her message I don't care what the
message she gave why is this message
doing so well in a time like
well why is her message why isn't Italy
that was a socialist country forcing
everybody to stay home this country that
was going through all the high taxes all
the high regulation all the high
[ __ ] why is it all of a sudden they
want somebody like her why is this
message resonating with the people well
listen I watched a few of her speeches
not just this speech okay so I'm not
going to rush to judgment and pretend I
know all the answers to freaking Italian
politics clearly she speaks with
authority and with conviction and
respect to her for that and respect to
her for being the first female prime
minister in the history of Italy so
respect and if you go through her
speeches she says things like world
problems require everyone's contribution
respect mutual respect for people
democratic system I'd look to unite not
divide so all these are all great
talking points the flip side is she's
anti-lgbt so there's going to be people
talking about that's literally The
Stance of their party what is it what
does that mean how does that manifest no
because people are called anti-lgbt here
in the United States because they don't
want people who I identify as a certain
gender to be able to use her party
agenda is rooted is rooted in
anti-immigration
what I'm saying is I don't even trust
that description because they say
anti-immigrant if somebody wants to have
a secure board yeah so I just don't
trust I'm okay with it I'm just I get it
yeah
not against you I'm saying I'm just
genuinely curious I'm just giving you
both sides of the equation I mean just
I'm not saying that I'm ready to anoint
her as the best leader ever just clearly
she's she's been getting a lot of
eyeballs and that's great just from that
speech she's pro-family and she's tired
of you know X or Y or Z or male she
she's tired of the Walk [ __ ] that's what
I got from that so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]